[Musica]
c'erano una volta ci sono e ci saranno
sempre
cenerentola cappuccetto rosso gretel
personaggi delle fiabe femminili donne
che attraverso la loro storia ci
raccontano la nostra storia
le fiabe sono nate nella notte dei tempi
quando l'uomo ha cominciato forte a
sentire l'esigenza di condividere
condividere le esperienze della vita
poi a un certo punto sono state relegate
al mondo dell'infanzia sono state
decorate sono state censurate i finali
sono stati cambiati c'è stato messo
addirittura un e vissero per sempre
felici e contenti ma la vita a una fine
non esiste nessuna fiaba della
tradizione in cui il finale sia così i
finali delle fiabe sono sorprendenti
magici lanciano sempre un sassolino
verso quel momento in cui quella fiaba
sarà di nuovo raccontata perché
l'essenza della fiaba è proprio questo
raccontarla ascoltarla e tornare a
raccontarla e se il suo potenziale è
stato assopito per un momento è perché
la fiaba è rivoluzionaria crea una
rivoluzione interiore ci mette in
cammino ci sveglia ci sprona ad essere
esattamente ciò che abbiamo scelto di
essere prima di arrivare qua un
pezzettino alla volta e quello che la
fiaba fa che io definisco commovente e
ricordarci che tutti nessuno escluso
possiamo in qualsiasi momento della
nostra vita essere felici
realizzati anche se abbiamo avuto un
inizio infelice difficile pensiamo
generale
una bambina di 8 anni che viene chiamata
al capezzale della madre morente
affrontare un lutto così grande per una
bambina così piccola la madre le prende
le mani stringe e poi le dice
promettimi promettimi bambina mia che
sarai sempre buona e gentile un adulto
lo sa che questa è una promessa che non
si può mantenere ma una bambina di 8
anni no e la madre finisce dicendo e
ricordati piccina che io da lassù ti
guarderò e così cenerentola diventa
buona e gentile ha promesso il padre
dopo un anno si risposa con una donna
bellissima con due figlie bellissime la
bruttina di casa era cenerentola e il
padre che non è mai andato via ma è
rimasto lì ha lasciato che le
sorellastre la matrigna trattassero
cenerentola con una domestica la misero
addirittura a dormire in mezzo alla
cenere per questo tutti la chiamavano
cenerentola un inizio davvero difficile
ma la vita tende all'armonia la natura
pensate alla natura tende all'armonia
all'equilibrio e quindi a tutti in un
certo momento arriva una chiamata una
sensazione quella sensazione di essere
in quel luogo in cui forse dovremmo
stare di più quella sensazione di avere
incontrato qualcuno che ci ha dato
qualcosa che forse ci farà scoprire
qualcosa di noi
e così ecco la chiamata di cenerentola
il re proclama un ballo dovrà durare tre
giorni il primo per incontrare il
secondo per conoscere e il terzo
la propria sposa la futura regina
ecco la chiamata e cenerentola per la
prima volta comincia a sentire il
desiderio di andare a quel ballo e
nonostante la matrigna e le sorellastre
le dicano di no quando la risposta alla
chiamata intimamente è data
arrivano gli aiuti soprannaturali che
nella vita di tutti i giorni possiamo
chiamare sincronicità incontri fortunati
in cenerentola sono degli uccellini che
la vestono la puliscono la preparano e
bellissima magnifica con comode
ballerine di seta cenerentola va al
ballo essi non una scarpetta di
cristallo tacco 15 ballerine di seta
comode passo dopo passo verso ciò che
desidera di più per scoprire un altro
pezzetto di sé
è vero quello che cappuccetto rosso e
così trattava dalla parata di russo non
ha paura
soprattutto nella capitale
l'unione per la musica molto piano come
mai interessato
così identità sembrato cazzo come
eccolo
[Musica]
ma scusa ma lo abbiamo fatto perché se
non disubbidì amo la mamma e non usciamo
dal sentiero conosciuto non possiamo
sbagliare inciampare cadere gioire fare
esperienza
sì a cappuccetto rosso è andata male il
lupo l'ha divorata ma la fiaba in questo
è magnifica
il cacciatore colui che uccide la bestia
apre la pancia del lupo fa uscire la
bambina e le dice prendi i sassi più
pesanti che ci sono e così cappuccetto
va in giardino premessa si più pesanti
li mette dentro la pancia del lupo
metterci una pietra sopra
arriva proprio da lì cuce la pancia del
lupo che quando si sveglia accade dal
letto e muore
la bambina va in giardino sorseggia il
vino mentre il cacciatore scuoia al lupo
ma il lupo si sa perde il pelo e non il
vizio e altri lupi cappuccetto
incontrerà ma mai e poi mai mi capiterà
di nuovo dice la bambina è infatti la
storia continua con cappuccetto che va
nel bosco incontra un altro lupo ma
questa volta è il lupo ad annegare nel
trogolo un altro pezzettino di sé gretel
hansel e gretel raccontano la storia di
due fratellini che vengono abbandonati
nel bosco perché in casa non c'è più
niente da mangiare
guardate pratica diffusa nel medioevo in
casa finiva il pane o morivano tutti o
qualcuno forse si salvava così si
prendevano i bambini e si abbandonavano
nel bosco
la storia di hansel e gretel però è la
storia di gretel una bambina che non è
capace di fare nulla senza il fratello
al punto che quando finiscono nella casa
della strega dice sarebbe stato meglio
essere divorati dalle bestie feroci
almeno sarà
sono stati insieme dipendenza affettiva
grave la strega la guarda e anche qui
spostiamo per un attimo al punto di
vista
usciamo dallo stereotipo che le streghe
sono cattive la strega si sacrifica
insegna gretel l'arte del cucinare la fa
diventare una donna la fa piangere o si
grate il piange disperata ma impara fin
tanto che a un certo punto la chiamata
arriva anche per lei l'ha chiamata ed è
un pensiero lucido che le attraversa la
mente la butto nel fuoco la gretel
dell'inizio non avrebbe mai avuto un
pensiero del genere ma dopo essere stata
in cucina dopo essere stata da sola dopo
essere stata separata fisicamente dal
suo fratello che è stato messo nelle
segrete gretel pensa la butto nel fuoco
e lo fa lo fa poi scende giù nelle
segrete e libera il fratello escono
dalla casa della strega si trovano
davanti a un grande corso d'acqua e per
la prima volta di fronte a una paperella
che si offre di trasportare tutti e due
fratelli dall'altra parte dice no no
hansel andremo divisi prima tu
e poi io è cambiata gretel è diventata
una donna
e così vedete come le fiabe in modo
semplice in modo diretto ci raccontano
qualcosa che ci riguarda più noi grandi
perché abbiamo fatto esperienza
l'ascolto del bambino e un ascolto
passivo vede cappuccetto rosso e la
identifica come cappuccetto rosso
io prima quando vi ho parlato del
disobbedire voi avete visto voi stessi
quando avete disubbidito è un'altra
interazione e allora spero dopo questa
chiacchierata che vi prenderete un tempo
non so bene quando non so bene dove
perché riguarda solo voi in cui
chiudendo gli occhi verrà davanti a voi
chiara e cristallina un'immagine di come
volete essere per essere felici e una
volta arrivata a quell'immagine arriverà
anche una chiamata ve lo giuro
e sarà una chiamata cristallina e allora
a quel punto spero che indosserete
scarpette comode come cenerentola
spero che butterete nel fuoco come
gretel tutti i pensieri negativi che vi
ostacolo alla durante il cammino e spero
che come cappuccetto sbaglierete per
imparare ad essere davvero davvero
felici audaci e brillanti grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]